researchers say our current way of
farming is not future proof
the environment is facing dramatic
challenges like declining biodiversity
and soil quality as well as global
warming and co2 emissions change is
necessary
[Music]
why agriculture is not future
because the way we're doing it we're
doing agriculture
in big monocultures
five ten twenty hundred hectares of
exactly the same everywhere
and it's the same as covet 19
social distancing if you put a lot of
genetically exactly the same individuals
close together
then the pest and disease spreads very
quickly
but at the same time and you see the
same you see the same in agriculture
actually here
so big surfaces of the same crop and
then we have to protect these crops with
pesticides
at the other hand we are doing our
agriculture with heavy machines
and these heavy machines
cause
soil compaction
and because of the subsoil compaction
water cannot infiltrate
but also when there's a drought
you have too little water you have to do
everything in a layer of
25 centimeters so
um soil compaction soil structure
is also a problem with the current way
of agriculture in the past
agronomy was following technology what
we knew now is that technology is
inspired by ecology
you